the northern ireland secretary
brandon lewis has just been giving me
his take on the political impasse in
northern are you satisfied with
what he told me and the way he's
handling it
well no there's been a really tough
lead-up to the challenges in northern
ireland there was two years ago there
was a deal that was negotiated by
brandon's predecessor which put forward
a raft of different measures which
needed legislation in westminster none
of it has been legislated for so some of
the key things are cultural packages
which would have introduced languages
things to do measures to deal with the
legacy issues of the violence in
northern ireland all of these have been
bundled and mismanaged uh in in the
years since that and none of it's been
introduced so that's destabilized
the system the the politics of northern
ireland and then put into the middle of
that of course is a prime minister that
goes to northern ireland makes an
absolute solemn promise there'll be no
border down the irish sea and it has no
intention of honoring that promise and
in fact breaks it straight away and this
has put a division right down you know a
schism right down northern ireland at a
time when politics is already fragile
so the good friday agreement is under
huge pressure at the moment because we
have a a government that doesn't
represent all of northern ireland it
only represents part of the politics of
northern ireland we have a northern
ireland secretary who who doesn't really
engage right across all of the
communities in northern ireland and
unfortunately when the stormont
collapsed brandon lewis gets on a plane
to washington he doesn't get on a plane
to belfast where he is needed to bring
people together and start to hammer out
a deal that will get storm on up and
running again so i am afraid that this
is a government who has played fast and
loose with the good friday agreement and
all of the measures which has delivered
police
peace stability and economic growth in
northern ireland and that's a real worry
so to be clear you are saying that the
uh decision by the unionists to
withdraw
their leader uh from the first
minister's post
and the essential paralysis of that
government is really boris johnson and
brandon lewis's fault it's not not
really anything to do with the northern
ireland parties
all political leaders or politicians
must take accept responsibility for
their own actions and
uh
i'm saying that the dup themselves have
been very explicit about that they're
not you know always blaming others but
there is a key thing here you know if
you look at the what the dup have said
and you look at the what the leader
jeffrey donaldson has said
it is very very clear when you look at
the world through their eyes they have
had a set of bargains with the tory
party and with boris johnson and every
one of the promises they've been made by
boris johnson has been broken to broken
they have been lied to repeatedly by
boris johnson and then we find out just
last week when jeffrey donaldson said
the prime minister has told him that the
protocol negotiations that are currently
underway only have a 30
uh possibility of success this is what
the prime minister is saying privately
there is no plan b
no
i just want to get clear though like my
government as to what that would that
would lead to this is the kind of thing
that is going on behind the scenes and
it is no wonder that is destabilizing
northern ireland okay i just want to get
clear that basically you're attributing
really the problems here to the
government in uh westminster and not
really anything to do with storm and if
if if labor
were in power what would you do to
resolve this let's not go back at what
you might not have done and all of that
but what would you be doing tomorrow to
resolve this
well not tomorrow i'd be there today i
wouldn't have gone to the whether i
would have cancelled that u.s trip and i
would have been there from the very
moment
and telling me what you would not have
done just tell me what you would have
done
what would you do that's what i'm saying
i would be there and i wouldn't have
left if i was secretary of state i
wouldn't let you do that get people
around the table figure out some of the
challenges and make things get things
onto the record
there have been promises made about the
protocol for example i think the
government have played fast and loose
with its words about the protocol it's
clear they don't think the negotiations
are going to succeed they have no plan b
in place and if they do trigger article
16 it will have impact implications
right the way across the whole of the uk
economy not just impact in limited ways
as it is currently the northern ireland
economy so all of these things there's
been double speak from the government
there will be no doubt
in the labour party and we will return
to the principle of the labour party
being the honest broker that northern
ireland needs
but mr carl so jeffrey johnson spoke to
us last week and the problem was that he
uh
he said some things about the government
he said the government could pay more
attention but essentially his objection
was to the way that the protocol
operates
what would you do differently about the
protocol than what with the protocol we
have been clear how would you get rid
around the table but what would you
actually do what would you put to the eu
to solve the problem uh that of the
objection to the way it operates right
now
so the protocol has to evolve the labour
party has said that but the way to make
the protocol evolve is actually to have
functional relationships with the eu at
the moment they are dysfunctional liz
truss is still making the mistake that
david frost made by negotiating via
op-ed in the telegraph with the eu they
are not coming to any clear arrangements
we need a deal on veterinary services
that should be negotiable because
actually both sides have a very clear
landing zone for that and we need to
move on into the future to some more
consumer products i think we all know
where this is going the problem is that
it's not acceptable to a small faction
in the tory party that have the boris
johnson the prime minister to ransom
right now including this trust who's
playing to them because of her own
leadership ambitions the labour party
will incrementally and in a solid way
move forward
adding on to the deal improving the deal
and showing that each aspect of the new
deal will work over time to build the
trust with the eu at the moment the
government is not acting in good faith
and it hasn't acted in good faith it has
delivered a deal that it's trying to
distance itself from this is the deal
boris johnson negotiated it is his deal
he didn't
okay could we move on to an area where
the government is not responsible where
we can talk about what
labour where labour is actually in
charge and talk about what labour does
um
and i want to talk about policing uh you
used to be shadow justice minister was
the mayor of london right to withdraw
his confidence from um the met police
commissioner
well there's a lot of discussion around
our country at the moment about people
at the top of organizations uh accepting
responsibility and what that actually
means so yes unfortunately it got to the
point where cressida dick had to accept
responsibility for all of the ongoing uh
revelations and inaction with with
reform in the police and sadiq khan
clearly got to the point where he
decided that she needed to leave and
actually that was what accepting
responsibility for the person at the top
meant i just wish that boris johnson
would do the same in the way that he has
mismanaged our country and broken the
rules
i'm not saying chris who's broken the
rules but she has failed to implement
the changes that have been needed over
time
it would be great we do spend quite a
lot of time uh saying the words boris
johnson this program would be great if
we we talked about somebody else let's
continue with the issue of the met um
the mayor supported her reappointment
just a few months ago what what changed
well there's just more because most of
the events that
they quoted happened before down over
time so if you look at the revelations
that came out of the charing cross
police station the the independent
report revealed extreme misogyny and
other issues there not not just sexism
not the sort of thing that people could
put down to a way of interpreting the
behavior there there was extreme
misogyny now that's a new revelation on
top of all of the different revelations
which have come out from sarah everard
and beyond the public need change they
need they need to know that change
actually is taking place so i'm afraid
that this has been going ongoing it has
been ongoing for too long and the public
are just starting to wonder now there
was a a poll that's just come out
recently where now by only 43
of the public believe that the police
are able to tackle crime in the right
way this is the first time we've had
these kind of low figures before people
are losing confidence not just uh in the
police but the people who are managing
the police in the home office and the
home secretary herself
so something has to change and
unfortunately that has to start at the
top and we need a new approach it is
really sad because i know firsthand just
how dedicated the vast majority of
police are and the incredible job that
police do there are a lot of women
police officers who feel
uh very strongly about the issues that
are going on themselves this isn't just
you know people outside the police force
complaining about the people inside the
police force there are people inside the
police who are desperate for change in
reform that the public need and the
police need those people need to be
empowered uh yvette cooper today is
releasing a five-point plan to do so
which starts with putting women and
violence against women and girls uh as a
priority for the home office which needs
to be a priority for the police force in
terms of reform going forward but also
looking at all the other measures which
need to be proactively changed in the
police force including whistleblowing
including use of social media
forgiveness
can i interrupt you just first sorry
sorry to interrupt you but before we
have that much time left before we
uh move on i would like to um give you
the chance to say something about the
situation in ukraine
so
starman made a well-published sized
visit to nato
uh headquarters uh this week obviously i
think to reinforce the um
view that labour supports nato now
brandon lewis
has just been telling me that
the government will be introducing fresh
legislation that will allow the
government to confiscate the assets of
putin's friends but um as i said to him
the government's talked tough on this
before
do you think this time that there will
be an effective regime put in place and
what would that look like for labor
i have absolutely no confidence that the
government are equipped to deal with
this simply because when you look at all
the taxation reforms that they they have
made to date they're doing so not in the
interests of the british economy they're
doing it in the interests of the people
who donate money to the tory party and
that includes a lot of russian people
we're not going to get the kind of
reforms that we need what we need to do
is have they are not doing transparency
laws we need to know for example
who is owning property particularly in
london and very expensive property
because at the moment there are all
sorts of very very easy ways that people
oligarchs and people with lots of
russian money who are laundering money
via the property market are doing so and
are able to hide it we need to reform
the law so that property is transparent
secondly companies house there are a lot
of people who are setting up very dodgy
companies in this country
and is and and companies house enables
uh russians to hide who are the ultimate
owners of these companies who are
investing money in our country who are
seeping money into our our economy we
need transparency
about transparency and got that point
but just quite as a last question really
once you know and labor has already
named some of the people that you're
referring to what would you do about
them would you take confiscate their
properties would you freeze their bank
accounts what would you do
well we already have because labour
passed the uh
the unexplained wealth orders labor
party you know brought this this
legislation in but this government
doesn't use them so we do already have
the powers if people don't have it
explained wealth or we believe that the
origins of wealth are coming from uh you
know criminal activity or they shouldn't
they don't belong in our country the
powers are there they're just not used
so if the lord needs updating then of
course the labor party supports that
margaret hodges had a almost lifelong
career in politics trying to clear up
the dodgy money that's coming into our
economy the
magnining uh acts came from the
sanctions yeah
margaret hodge and labour party sort of
has implemented and support those
supported those acts we need to find the
source of
this money and then we need to act upon
it